Di bab ini kita akan menjelajahi
bagaimana komputer kuantum dan klasik
bekerja sama untuk menyelesaikan salah satu tantangan terpenting
dalam sains: memperkirakan energi molekul dan material secara akurat
Kita bisa mencapai ini
dengan menggunakan quantum circuit
untuk menghasilkan contoh-contoh bid
yang kemudian akan diproses lebih lanjut
dan didiagonalisasi menggunakan sejumlah algoritma
dalam keluarga rutin ini
seperti SQV dan SKG, dan ada seluruh kursus di
platform IBM Quantum yang didedikasikan
untuk metode-metode itu dan yang terkait
Untuk keperluan kita di bagian ini,
penjelasannya akan singkat saja
Baik kamu pakai SQV maupun SKG,
tujuanmu adalah menemukan eigenvector
dan eigenvalue untuk matriks Hamiltonian
Matriks ini mungkin menggambarkan energi suatu sistem fisika
atau kimia, tapi kerangka yang sama
juga bisa menangani banyak jenis masalah lain
seperti logistik. Kadang-kadang
matriks-matriks ini sangat besar
sehingga mereduksi dimensi
matriks sambil mempertahankan yang penting
dari ground state
bisa sangat berharga — itulah tujuan di SQV
Kita pakai komputer kuantum untuk menghasilkan subspace yang berguna
yaitu yang mengandung ground state
Kita lalu bisa memproyeksikan matriks Hamiltonian kita
ke subspace itu, yang menyisakan kita
dengan matriks kecil yang akan
jauh lebih mudah untuk dianalisis secara diagonal
menggunakan komputasi klasik berperforma tinggi. Kita melakukan ini
dengan menyiapkan keadaan kuantum percobaan
yang sering disebut ansatz
dan melakukan pengukuran untuk mengambil sampel dari ansatz itu
dalam basis komputasi. Itu memberi kita
sampel subspace dalam basis komputasi
tapi yang sebetulnya ingin kita temukan
adalah ground state yang sebenarnya. Bagaimana
kalau sampel subspace kita tidak mengandung
semua komponen yang diperlukan?
Kalau kita pilih ansatz yang lebih baik,
kita mungkin mendapat perkiraan ground state yang lebih baik
Itu membawa kita ke sample-based
Krylov quantum diagonalization, atau SKUDY. Di SKUDY,
kita mulai dengan ansatz
seperti sebelumnya, tapi kemudian kita terapkan quantum gate yang mendekati
evolusi waktu dari sistem fisika
Bisa ditunjukkan bahwa dengan beberapa asumsi,
ini menghasilkan jaminan tentang tumpang tindih antara evolusi waktu
ansatz dan ground state yang sebenarnya
Kedua algoritma ini dimulai dengan matriks Hamiltonian yang sangat besar.
Cara kerjanya agak berbeda,
tapi dalam kedua kasus, bagian kuantum algoritma menghasilkan
subspace yang memungkinkan kita mengecilkan matriks kita,
di mana kita berharap dapat mempertahankan fitur utama dari ground state
Lalu di mana komputasi klasik berperforma tinggi berperan
untuk Hamiltonian yang paling besar
dan untuk perkiraan ground state yang paling akurat?
Bahkan matriks yang sudah diproyeksikan ini bisa cukup besar
Makanya, memanfaatkan kemampuan komputer klasik yang lebih kuat
bisa membantu kita bukan hanya
mendapatkan hasil yang lebih baik,
tapi juga memungkinkan kita menangani masalah yang lebih besar
Untuk menyatukan semuanya,
kita bisa merepresentasikan algoritma berbasis sampel
sebagai kombinasi dari berbagai model pemrograman
pada sekumpulan sumber daya heterogen
Misalnya, kita bisa merepresentasikan algoritma kita
sebagai alur kerja task, di mana kita punya sebuah task
untuk persiapan quantum circuit yang tumpang tindih
dengan keadaan target kita, diikuti oleh sebuah task
untuk transpilasi yang hanya membutuhkan sumber daya klasik
Berikutnya yang akan dieksekusi adalah task
yang menggunakan primitif untuk menjalankan quantum circuit kita,
yang jelas membutuhkan sumber daya kuantum.
Lalu kita punya task post-processing yang itu sendiri
mungkin berupa algoritma diagonalisasi paralel
yang berjalan di beberapa node
Selain itu, kita mungkin ingin menjalankan
salah satu algoritma itu berkali-kali
saat kita memvariasikan ansatz kita,
atau menjalankannya sepenuhnya secara paralel
dengan populasi yang berbeda-beda
Sekarang mari kita satukan semuanya dengan SKUDY
dalam kode. Berikut semua file task kita
dan berikut semua file submission kita
Dalam task mapping, kita menyiapkan circuit.
Dalam langkah optimisasi, kita jalankan circuit ke backend terbaik.
Dalam task eksekusi, kita mengambil sampel bitstring
dari keadaan yang disiapkan oleh
ISA circuit kita.
Yang kita dapat dari langkah sebelumnya,
lalu kita lakukan post-processing.
Jadi sekarang kita siap untuk mengirimkan
alur kerja eksekusi kita.
Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat, semuanya berjalan secara berurutan
dengan dependensi. Mari kita tunggu
hasilnya dan kita bisa memeriksa file output kita.
Ini adalah file output dari langkah optimisasi,
di mana kita punya ISA circuit kita.
Dan akhirnya mari kita periksa iterasi
akhir kita.
Dari jadwal.
Dan itulah demonstrasi singkat dari alur kerja SKUDY.
Semua kode akan tersedia di bagian teks
atau di deskripsi di bawah.
Dan itulah, kita sudah membahas beberapa
konsep dan contoh yang bisa membantumu mulai dengan
pengelolaan program hybrid kompleks. Tentu saja,
kalau kamu tertarik, ini hanya menggaruk permukaan dari
semua yang bisa kamu lakukan dengan kombinasi sumber daya kuantum
dan klasik. Untuk menjelajahi lebih lanjut,
lihat dokumentasi dan tutorial lainnya
di platform IBM Quantum,
dan pastikan kamu melihat sumber daya yang dibagikan di bagian teks
atau deskripsi untuk lebih banyak materi
dan software. Terima kasih sudah menonton.
Ya, itu dia.